[संगीत]
खुदा
मैं हूं
सो प्रीवियस जो जो लेक्चरर्स थे वह भी
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है डाटा को समझना के लिए
तो वह एक बार देख कर आना अगर जो लोग अभी
सारे लेक्चर में ए रहे हैं तो
बट फिर थोड़ा बहुत तो अपना जाएगा ही मतलब
प्रैक्टिकल वाला जो पार्ट है उसका डिवीजन
वापस से हो ही जाएगा थोड़ा थोड़ा तो उसका
पिछला आता ही है ठीक है तो इस बार शायद हम
थोड़ा रिवीजन भी तो ध्यान नहीं देंगे
क्योंकि थोड़ा बहुत हो ही जाएगा
तो उसके लिए
तो बेसिकली
बनाना सीखे थे तो आज अपन सीखेंगे टेबल को
उड़ना ठीक है
[संगीत]
जान के बाद में नीचे
ठीक है फिर यहां पर अपना रन एसक्यूएल
कमांडेंट
जो पासवर्ड
आएगा
जल्दी से बता दो की अगर मैंने कोई टेबल
बना राखी है तो मैं उसका स्ट्रक्चर कैसे
देख सकता हूं मैंने लास्ट लेक्चर में
बताया था इसके लिए तो प्लीज मुझे टेबल का
स्ट्रक्चर देखने का है तो मुझे जल्दी से
बताओ की मैं स्ट्रक्चर कैसे देख सकता हूं
एक टेबल का अपन और थोड़ा और आगे बाढ़ सके
जब तक मैं एक नोटपैड खोल लेट हूं
इंस्टॉल कर सकते हो मैंने फर्स्ट दे पर
बताया था ठीक है तो वैसे ही रहेगा
ठीक है तो अभी जो टेबल मैंने बनाया है इस
टेबल को मैं उड़ाऊंगा
तो उसके ऊपर वाले कमांड में जाएगा
ऑब्जेक्ट स्टूडेंट नोट ए टेबल
ठीक है तो यह टेबल
उदा देती है एक कमांड होती है जिससे अपन
टेबल के अंदर का जो डाटा है वो उदा सकता
है ये ये जो चीज लिखी हुई है ना इसको डाटा
मत समझना यह डाटा नहीं है अपना ये अपना
टेबल का स्ट्रक्चर है ये कलम के नाम से
डाटा अलग होता है नेम्स वगैरा ये चीज अलग
होती है
ठीक है डाटा बोलो डाटा बोलो एक ही बात है
तो वो भी अपन आगे चलकर देखेंगे
तो देखो
प्राइमरी के अंदर क्या राहत है मैं एक बार
मतलब
हां ठीक है तो
यह मेरा पान है लेकिन ये पहने गई थी ना
मिट्टी जाता है
प्राइमरी
रूल होता है ठीक है
डाटा एंट्री के वक्त में ठीक है डाटा
इस रूल्स को इंपोज करते हैं ये सारे रूल्स
छेद टाइप के रूल्स अपने पोस्ट कर सकते हैं
ठीक है ना
तो सबसे पहले
यूनिक होना चाहिए
बीच में रिलेशनशिप होगा ही होगा ठीक है
यह अपने स्टेटस है जी जिंदगी के स्टेटस है
मैरिड नोट मैरिड सिंगल कमिटेड यह वही
फॉरेन की यह डिफाइन करता है
लेकिन अलग-अलग हनी चाहिए इसके एग्जांपल
बताया जिसके अंदर फोन नंबर है एग्जांपल हो
सकता है अच्छा ठीक है नॉर्मल के अंदर आपका
एड्रेस एड्रेस हो सकता है अच्छा एग्जांपल
ये भी कम राहत है की अगर आपने कुछ डाला है
डाटा के अंदर अगर आपने कुछ इनपुट कारी है
तो वो इनपुट लगा अगर आप लोग डाटा इनपुट
नहीं किया है तो उसकी जगह
चेक का फंडा तो मेरे को खुद के समझ में
नहीं आता बट कोई बात नहीं है तो अपन
पढ़ेंगे ठीक है जैसे हिस्ट्री अपन पढ़ने
हैं की भाई कुछ कम आई है नहीं आगे जाके बट
लोग बोलते हैं
कोई बात नहीं करनी पड़ती है वैसे ये भी
कुछ चीज हैं जो अपनों करनी पद रही है जो
अपुन को बता राखी है
तो ये अपने कांस्टेंट से एक बार फिर से
रिपीट कर दिया है बट अपन इसको जब
प्रैक्टिकल इंप्लीमेंटेशन देखेंगे इसका तो
इसको थोड़ा और डिपलाई अपन जान पाएंगे की
क्या चीज होती है इसके अंदर ठीक है तो
सबसे पहले अपन एक टेबल बना लेंगे
फिर से
केवल
मैंने कल ही बताया है
ओके टेबल टेबल नाम बहुत बढ़िया
बताओ यार
प्राइमरी की ठीक
है
अपना
नेक्स्ट
अब अपन यहां पर नाम लेते हैं
इसका साइज
खाली नहीं छोड़ने का राहत है ठीक है तो
चलो ठीक है
नियम हो गया
कांटेक्ट नंबर
दे देंगे
ठीक है अब मां लो कहना कौन कहां से मुझे
यह पता लगाने के लिए मैं है ना यहां पर
स्टेट का भी ऑप्शन दाल देता हूं उसे शरीर
के अंदर वायर केयर
तू
ठीक है
ना अब मां लो कोई ना
अपना स्टेट नहीं डालता है मतलब
वो अपने सिटी दाल देता है तो मैं अपने
डिफॉल्ट में करता हूं ना ये सब स्ट्रिंग
क्रिएट करेंगे तो अपन यहां पे स्टिंग
डालेंगे
ठीक है
ठीक है पैसे में दाल दिया यहां पर
देखो यह ना यह चीज देखो
आज आईटी इस ही लिया जाता है तो मां लो अगर
मैंने यहां पर
स्टेट के अंदर डाटा इनपुट करते हैं वक्त
में अगर मैंने आरएस मॉल दाल दिया तो वो
डिफॉल्ट वाला कैसे में नहीं जा रहा होगा
वो जो आपने डाला है उसके अंदर कैसे में
जाएगा ठीक है
तो उससे फर्क नहीं पड़ेगा
फर्क नहीं पड़ेगा उससे लेकिन जो स्ट्रिंग
वाला चीज है वो ऐसा चीज ही रहेगा
ठीक है
वह डिपार्मेंट
अच्छा शायद
[संगीत]
यहां पर इंटर ढाबा के फिर यहां पे चेंज
करने पढ़ेंगे तो उसके बदले में यहां पर
ऐसे कर दूंगा
अब मां लो की
मुझे
देखा हूं ठीक है ना अपना अगला जो है
कमांड के बड़े में
कल मैंने बताया की मैं तुमको भी डीएल के
बड़े में बता रहा हूं इंस्टाग्राम नहीं
आता है ठीक है ना यार मैं डीएमएल के अंदर
ए जाता है लेकिन अभी अपने इसी समझ रहे हैं
इस कांस्टेंट वगैरा के बड़े में तो अपन को
प्रैक्टिकल भी करना मांगता है यार भाई
अपने ये सब बता दिया है ये हवा में बातें
हो रही है इसका इंप्लीमेंटेशन हो कैसे रहा
एक्चुअली बैक हैंड के अंदर मतलब वसंत नहीं
दिखे रहा है फ्रंट के अंदर अपन बनाए कोई
बात नहीं
[प्रशंसा]
पट कर रहे हैं तो सच में डिलीट कर भी रहा
है की नहीं मैंने क्या सही बताया है की
नहीं तो वो चीज भी बहुत ज्यादा भटक जाति
है
तो यहां पर अब इंसर्ट के लिए मुझे क्या
लिखना पड़ेगा सीधा
इंसर्ट इन
टेबल नाम
दो तरीके होते हैं
ठीक है पहले तरीका आगे चलकर बताएंगे
यहां पर वालुज भरनी है
ठीक
है
1001 दे देता हूं
और सबसे पहले नाम देता हूं उनको
इतनी करके इनको
इसके अंदर
कांटेक्ट नंबर के अंदर सॉरी
यह तो स्टेट के अंदर मैं यहां पर डिफॉल्ट
राजस्थान है
तो आप स्टेट का है आपका मतलब एड्रेस नहीं
पूछ रहा हूं आपसे ताकि मतलब मेरे को सोचना
पड़ेगा
इसके लिए
गुजरात
के अंदर ही रखो
खुद से अच्छा लगता है
ठीक है
अगर आप अपने इसमें दबाओगे
तो वह चीज तो है
यहां पर क्या है
प्राइमरी
जस्ट पहले रिवाइज कराया नॉर्थ नल होना
चाहिए वो एक और यूनिक होना चाहिए ठीक है
ना तो देखो मैंने यहां पर 1001 जो है
यहां पर से कर दिया था इसके चक्कर के अंदर
102 लिखना हूं
तो यहां पर रो बन गया है बहुत अच्छे बहुत
अच्छे
ठीक है
स्किल क्वेरी का इंटरफेस भाई उसे से नहीं
कर रहे हैं वह एक तो दिखने में बाल अच्छा
नहीं लगता है ठीक है ना सिलाई अपुन देखो
सी ड्राइव में ज्यादा कम करेंगे ज्यादा
मजा आएगा क्योंकि आपको हर जगह जिओ पे कम
करने को मिली मिलेगा नहीं क्योंकि ये चीज
है ना आप में सर्वर पे कम करने वाले हैं
अपन ठीक है नहीं है हम वहां पर आपको कोई
जोई चीज नहीं आएगी आपको मदद करने के लिए
जैसे अगर आपसे खोलने हो तो हमें पीएसयू
मैं एडमिन के अंदर आप स्पेल शेर दाल सकते
हो तो वो आपको हर जगह गई बेस कम नहीं
मिलेगा आप मां लो कोई भी सर्वर के अंदर कम
कर रहे हो तो आप उससे क्या करोगे वहां पे
इंस्टॉल करना पड़ेगा सर्वर के अंदर सॉल्व
करना पड़ेगा फिर उसके अंदर आपको एसक्यूएल
से कनेक्ट करना पड़ेगा फिर बाद में आप
यहां पर कोई रीजन होगा तो जिओ ए पे कम
करने का सेंस बंता नहीं है ठीक है सब कुछ
से ही रहेगा
नीचे और पट आएगा कमांड आप हाईलाइट करो और
उन पर क्लिक करो वहां पर रन हो जाएगा ठीक
है
हर जगह मिले वो कंपलसरी नहीं है ठीक है
पारस सिंह
देखिए यहां पर
भारत सिंह
ने बताया था की आपको स्टार्ट से मैं बता
देगा की काफी दिक्कत है आपकी ठीक है ना बट
ये चीज कुछ लिमिट तक की ठीक थी मेरा
लोकेशन बताइए
इस्तेमाल करना पड़ेगा तो यहां पर
यह तो नंबर है
कांटेक्ट नंबर की जगह पर अपने यहां पर
यूनिक की डाला था
ठीक है
इसलिए वैसा हुआ
वैल्यू इंटर करते वक्त
यहां पर सीक्वेंस इसका ही रहेगा
वो मैं आपको बताऊंगा की जस्ट तूने विथ स
हां
मतलब भी उसके अंदर भी टेबल्स होती है
लेकिन
डाटा
उसे नहीं कर सकते
हो
इस कैसे में क्या है ना ये ऐसी ही टेबल है
ना आपके बनी हुई रहती है ठीक है
ठीक है ना आपके डाटा
राहत है सर्वे के अंदर आगे आईटी इसे राहत
है ठीक है ना
जब मैं सर्वर में कम कैसे हो रहा है वो
चीज अपने आप पर भी देख रहा है ठीक है ना
तो अभी मैं अगर यह पारस भाई का नंबर अभी
चेंज कर देता हूं तो उसके बाद में
तो देखो यहां पर अपना रॉक की रेट हो गया
था की
था
मैं यहां पर टैक्स लिख देता हूं
तो मैंने यहां पर इसको यहां से भी यहां पर
कॉपी करूंगा
तो आपको एजइटइज सरवर के अंदर कभी आपको
रिट्रीव करने को नहीं मिलेगा ठीक है ना
क्या आपने कहा प्राइमरी के डाला था कहां
वो सब कुछ डाला था वो आपको नहीं मिलता है
पता करने को ठीक है ना
चलेगा
तुझको यहां पर
और आगे बढ़ाने का है मुझे
और मालूम
करेंगे
[संगीत]
है तो यह सिंपल इंग्लिश जैसी रहती है
ना सिंपल इंग्लिश पर ही राहत है की रेड
टेबल
बना टेबल के नाम ये एमपी के नाम से तो
थोड़ा सिंपल सा ही राहत है इसका इंग्लिश
जैसे ही राहत है आप एक दौरा करोगे ना मतलब
एक दो बड़े में ए जाएगा लिटरली एक दो बार
करोगे तो अब मुझे चाट में बताओ की कौन-कौन
लोग प्रैक्टिस करता है यार इसमें जो मैंने
बताया था पिक्चर का
जब तक मैं आगे बढ़ता हूं यहां पे अंपायर
डालता हूं यहां पे 10 दाल देता हूं मतलब
105 दाल देता हूं
तो देखो इस कैसे में क्या रहेगा ना की
यहां पर
अगर आप कल नहीं कर रहे हो तो आपको चलना है
ना तो यहां पर जो कलम है आपको फिर इस कलम
के सीक्वेंस के हिसाब से चलना है जरूरी
नहीं है उसके अंदर तो यहां पर ये मैंने
आगे लिखा है ये एमपी को मैं बीच में घुसा
सकता हूं कोई दिक्कत नहीं होगा उसके अंदर
लेकिन
अपने कॉन्सेप्ट समझना है कॉन्सेप्ट यही है
की यहां पर मैं इसको कैसे भी लिखूं बट
मुझे जब मैंने यहां पर कल में स्पेसिफाई
किया है तो मुझे यहां पर अब वालुज भी उसे
कलम के हिसाब से ही डालनी है जब मैं
कांग्रेस में नहीं कर रहा था ऊपर तो मुझे
हर कलम डालना पद रहा था आ यहां मैसेज इस
सीक्वेंस के हिसाब से बट यहां पर मैंने
तीन ही कलम के बड़े में डाला है तो मैं
यहां पे तीन ही कलाम का बताऊंगा ठीक है
जब मैं अब एक कस्टम पड़ेगी
सिलेक्ट के बड़े में यह इतना सही नहीं है
सिलेक्ट इसके अंदर बहुत कुछ है लिटरली
बहुत कुछ है सिलेक्ट के अंदर सिलेक्ट पद
पद गया अपना शायद दो दिन अपना पूरा
सिलेक्ट ही चलने वाला है ठीक है ना मैं भी
कल से अपना सिलेक्ट चालू हो जाएगा बट आज
इसका एक छोटा सा चीज बता लोग सिलेक्ट क्या
करता है ना जो डाटा अपने डाला है अपने
उसके अंदर क्या कहते हैं टेबल के अंदर वो
दिखाने का कम करता है ठीक है ना चलिए
स्टार फ्रॉम स्टाइलिश भी बोल सकते हैं
स्टार का मतलब होता है सब कुछ मैं यहां पर
कॉलोनी
चाहिए लेकिन अभी स्टार्ट हो सके
हालांकि स्टार फ्रॉक
यहां पर उसका फोन नंबर भी ए गया देखो सबके
फोन नंबर से अलग दिखेंगे डिपार्मेंट
अब मां लो इसके अंदर मैंने ना यह लास्ट
वाला जो था मोहम्मद कैफ भाई का मैंने यहां
पर स्टेट डाला ही नहीं था ठीक है ना उसे
कैसे में क्या हुआ इसने बाय डिफॉल्टर यहां
पर राजस्थान ले लिया देखो क्यों लिया
क्योंकि अपने यहां पर स्टेट के अंदर ये
कांस्टेंट लगा रखा है पहले से ही डिफॉल्ट
परसों लगा रखा है राजस्थान अगर आप स्पेस
से अपन नहीं करेंगे तो राजस्थान डालेगा तो
ये चीज था अपना इसके अंदर
ठीक है
तो इंसर्ट के बड़े में यह दो चीज आपको
जानी जरूरी थी ठीक है ना
अपना टेबल का स्कीम मॉडिफाइड करने के कम
आता है
कमी रहते हैं पता नहीं क्यों जान कम हो
रहे हैं बट फिर भी मजा ए रहा है की नहीं
आप लोग जितने भी ए रहे हो
तो मजेदार तो है ठीक है अच्छी बात है
की नहीं
चलो बढ़िया बात है मजा ए जाता आप इसे
प्रैक्टिकल साथ में करते रहोगे तो आपको
मजा आएंगे
चलो लाइक से ए गए अच्छी बात है एक ही जगह
दबाना बार-बार
ठीक है कोई बात नहीं अपन आगे बढ़ते हैं अब
देखो दे एस सी से क्या हो रहा था ना डीएसई
एमपी से ये देखो ये अब अब आपको इस किम के
अंदर और टेबल के डाटा के अंदर आपको
अलग-अलग डिफरेंस पता करने पद गए होंगे
मतलब पता पद गए होंगे
अगर अपन को मां लो की अपनों ने कोई
प्रॉब्लम
है
तो मैं यहां पर लिखूंगा
ठीक है ना यहां पे सैलरी दाल देता हूं
सैलरी अपना नंबर्स के अंदर देता है
ठीक है तो मैं यहां पर
10 डिजिटल का डालता हूं आई होप आप सब लोग
को भी 10 डिजिटल से ऊपर कैसे सैलरी मिलेगी
देखो यह देखो अब यहां पे सैलरी का आया है
एक और बढ़िया में सैलरी के लिए कहानी आया
नहीं देखो ये है ना डाटा ऐसा लिखकर आए ये
थोड़ा और अकेले का दिक्कत है की थोड़ा
टेबल को थोड़ा ऊंचाई से करके दिखता है ये
इस चक्कर में आता है क्योंकि देखो मैंने
आपको दे देंगे तो दास दास है ये अपना वो
राहत है की अपने कितना इसके अंदर डाला है
अगर मैं इनको
कम कर दूंगा तो शायद थोड़ा ढंग से दिखाएगा
ये
करके भी देखेंगे
तो कल शायद नहीं देख पाएंगे
उड़ने वाले हैं
ठीक है अब जैसे मां लो मुझे कलम उड़ने का
भी है डिलीट करने का मुझे मालूम मुझे
डिपार्मेंट वाला तो कलम मुझे अच्छा नहीं ग
रहा मुझे इसको डिलीट करने का है तो मैं
क्या करूंगा अल्टर टेबल ये एमपी ठीक है ना
फिर इसके आगे यहां पर लिख दूंगा अपना
ड्रॉप
ड्रॉप करना है क्या करना है कलम मुझे
ड्रॉप करना है कौन सा कलर मुझे ड्रॉप करना
है
सब ड्रॉप हो सकते हैं कोई जरूरी नहीं है
की यार जो मैंने रिसेंटली एड की वजह से
सैलरी मैंने एड किया है वही ड्रॉप हो सकता
है या जो लास्ट था ये पैटर्न में मत जाना
ठीक है कोई भी आप कलम ड्रॉप कर सकते हो
है तो इस चक्कर के अंदर मैंने यहां पर कर
दिया जैसे बाद में कोई मोडिफिकेशन हो जाति
है लेकिन एक चीज याद रखना अल्टर का मेली
इस्तेमाल तभी करना जब आपने टेबल बना दी हो
और फ्रैशली आप टेबल के चेंज कर दो क्योंकि
क्या राहत है डाटा इनपुट करने के बाद अगर
टेबल में चेंज करते हो तो आपको बाद में
डाटा में भी चेंज करने पद सकते हैं
इसी के लिए तो कभी-कभी क्या होता है ना की
डाटा आपको टेबल अल्टर नहीं करने देता है
यह भी कैसे होता है
तो इसलिए यही राहत है की आखिर टेबल बना तो
उसके बाद में ही अब टेबल में कुछ अल्टरेशन
करनी हो तो वही क्यों नहीं कर दो डाटा
इनपुट करने के बाद या लास्ट डेट इनपुट
करने के बाद में अल्टरेशन मत करना
कलम मॉडिफाइड करना है
कांस्टेंट लगाना है
ठीक है ना
तो उसकी इसके अंदर
15 घंटे का है तो हमें लिख दूंगा अल्टर
केवल
लगा दूंगा
यार भाई यह कैसे मतलब यह इसके हमें नंबर
डालेंगे तो फिर आपको सामने कुछ अलग ही एरर
सीखेंगे तो वो एरर्स अपन ना देख सके इसके
लिए मैं आपको एक चीज बार-बार ऑन कर रहा
हूं
होता यार ऐसा मतलब आप नए-नए हो तो अगर
आपको जब इंटरेस्ट नहीं लगता है ना तो अपने
मां में चल होती है चल सब कम यहां पे
इस्तेमाल करूंगा हालांकि ये बहुत अलग है
ठीक है चलो बहुत मस्ती है इसलिए तो यहां
पर मैं मेरा ₹20000 देता हूं ठीक है यहां
पर मैं फिर से इसको एड कर दूंगा मैंने कहा
बताया है की भाई
तुम्हारा ओरिजिनल
हो गई है तो मैं अभी यहां पर डीएससी
करूंगा
ठीक है अब यह तो सीधे कॉलर वालों की चीज
हुई यार देखो अब मां लो मुझे टेबल का नाम
ही बदलने का है ठीक है ना उसे कैसे मैं
क्या करूंगा ना
अल्टर केवल
तू
एम्पलाई
ठीक है
टेबल कोड लिख दिया
सिंपल इंग्लिश हमारी थोड़ा बहुत समझोगे ना
जैसे मैंने तुमको बताया था मेरी भी
इंग्लिश खराब है मतलब फिर भी इसके अंदर
थोड़ी बहुत कमिंग इस्तेमाल हुई है
अब मैं अगर यहां पर करूंगा तो टेबल दोएस
नोट एक्जिस्ट दिखाएगा क्यों दिखाएगा मुझे
जल्दी चाटने बताओ
मेवाती
टेबल का नाम बादल दिया
यहां पर
सिस्टम
बड़ा दिए कल अपने कम कर दिए हैं ठीक है ना
अब मां लो मुझे कलम का ही चेंज करना है
नाम उसे कैसे में मैं क्या करूंगा
प्रीमियम करना है मुझे क्या
कौन सा कलम मुझे डेनिम करना है
कांटेक्ट नंबर को मैं यहां पर फोन नंबर
लिखना चाहता हूं
कांटेक्ट नंबर तू फोन
कांटेक्ट नंबर
वह सब मेरे को एड करना है तो मैं कैसे एड
करूंगा अल्टर के थ्रू तो मुझे यह चीज आप
बताओगे
यह आप लोग का टास्क रहेगा
जो मैं
और में भी बताऊंगा आपको जब मैं थैंक यू
बर मत होना
तो अब अपना नेक्स्ट
की ड्रॉप से कोई टेबल के टेबल
हो जाता है बट मैंने आपको उसके साथ में
कुछ भी बताई थी की अगर अपन चाहते हैं की
टेबल के अंदर का वैल्यू जोड़े
तो उसे कैसे में अपन क्या करते हैं
एक बार ट्रंकते का एक ड्रॉबैक क्या है मैं
आपको बताता हूं ट्रंकेट अगर आपने एक बार
इस्तेमाल कर लिया तो आप कभी रोल बैक नहीं
कर सकते हो रोलबैक का मतलब मैंने आपको
फर्स्ट सेशन में बताया था क्या राहत है
ठीक है मेरे पीछे राहत हूं की मां लो आप
चेंज करते हो ट्रंकेट से कुछ ना कुछ तो आप
मापनी से उसके पिछले स्टेटमेंट नहीं जा
सकते हो की आपको डाटा फिर से मिल जाए
ट्रंकते पूरा रिकॉर्ड खाली कर देता है
टेबल नहीं उड़ता है टेबल के रिकॉर्ड वो
उदा देता है ठीक है ना तो यहां पर मैं
सीरियस हूं
ये आप ट्रंकते का इस्तेमाल तभी करना जब
आपकी बहुत खुलना शो कंपनी के साथ में ठीक
है
ठीक है
दबाऊंगा तो नो रोज सिलेक्टेड या दिखा रहा
है मतलब इसके अंदर एक भी रो नहीं है
ट्रंकते के बड़े में था यह पूरा डाटा उदा
देता है और इसमें उदा दिया है एक कमांड के
अंदर और इससे अपन कभी भी रिट्रीव नहीं कर
सकते हैं आप इसे पुराने स्टेट में नहीं जा
सकते हैं
तो
मैंने आप लोगों को एक टास्क बताया था की
आप लोगों को प्राइमरी की वगैरा एड करके
दिखाने का है तो
आपको वह जो टास्क अपना
कंक्रीट के बड़े में
आप पूरा टेबल का अंदर का जो डाटा इनपुट
करते हुए डाटा एक बड़ी में एक कमांड से सर
का सर डाटा उदा दिया जाएगा जो कभी रोल बैक
नहीं हो सकता है ठीक है ना तो देखो जैसे
अभी ये दे तू का है वैसे भी डेट थ्री का
भी पोस्ट ए जाएगा उसे पोस्ट में आपने आपको
अपने कमांड लिखने की है और स्क्रीनशॉट
डालने का है आपके डीएससी करके ठीक है ना
और यहां पर आपको पोस्ट के कमेंट के अंदर
आपको दाल देने का है की आपने कैसे एक
प्राइमरी की एड किया ऑर्डर कमांड के थ्रू
वही आपका छोटा
लेकर जाएंगे
ऑलवेज हर तो इंप्रूव योरसेल्फ और युटुब
आपको किसी कलम में एड करके दिखाना है
विद योर अल्टर कमांड
यह वेबसाइट
बनाते हैं
ठीक है
ग्लोबल बना रहे हो तो ग्लोबल एसक्यूएल
इसके बस से सर्टिफिकेट रहती है नहीं तो
आपने सर्वर के अंदर आपको एसक्यूएल का
सर्वर इंस्टॉल करना पड़ेगा स्क्रीनशॉट
करना पड़ेगा इंस्टॉल करने के बाद हम चाहते
हो तो कोई सा भी सर्विस कर सकते हो और कल
भी इंस्टॉल कर सकते हो आप अपने
स्टोर करने के बाद में आपको जैसा मैंने
अभी यहां पे स्टाइल्स बताया
आपको कनेक्ट करके
फिर अपने वेबसाइट के थ्रू आपको कमांड
भेजनी पड़ती है ठीक है ना
बता रहा हूं की ऐसा होता है
डेवलपमेंट के अंदर बताया जाएगा
ठीक है
नीड वॉइस
मतलब कैसा वॉइस एक्टिव क्या एक्टिव वॉइस
मतलब एकदम तेज तरीके से बोलूं की कैसा
वॉइस एक्टिव
का फर्स्ट लेक्चर देखोगे तो मैं तो बहुत
तेज बोला था ठीक है ना वहां एकदम एक्टिव
लिए मैंने बोला था लेकिन वो चीज होती है
ना बेगिनेर वगैरा को वो चीज समझ में नहीं
आई है
तो इसलिए थोड़ा मैं धीरे बोलना हूं और
थोड़ा रुक रुक
है उन लोगों को यह चीज अच्छी समझ में आया
इसलिए बताओ ना मैं थोड़ा मतलब ऐसा
प्रोफाइल
करता हूं ताकि अगर आपको सुनने में कुछ
गलती हो या मेरे बोलने में कुछ गलती हो गई
हो तो वो सही हो जाता है इसके लिए बस
चलो अच्छा अगर आप लोग को अच्छे से बढ़िया
लगा हो तो
थैंक यू टाटा बाय-बाय गुड नाइट शब्बा खैर
और जय हिंद वंदे मातरम और